how have you stayed humble in the sense
but also like not being taken advantage
of because I don't think people are
taking advantage of me when I'm making a
decision if I choose to be kind there's
no taking advantage of that I chose to
be kind too many people are fake kind
they do something with the expectation
of a count or something I think that's
the definition of manipulation not
kindness I hear it all the time I always
talk about nice guys finished first and
people are like yeah okay garyvee but I
get walked all over I'm like that's
because you probably weren't actually
kind you add expectation to your
kindness yeah like yeah when I'm in the
concept of kindness there's nothing you
can do to take advantage of me I gave
you everything I didn't want anything
the reward is me being kind my selfish
part of that was the feeling I get when
I'm kind yeah and I think a lot of
people fear that vulnerability yeah a
lot of people are scarcity mentality
like whether it's a check or your time I
think a lot of people lack the humility
to be actually kind